bonsoir à qui j'ai confiance en vous
monsieur le maire vous voulez jacky que
vous me prêtez l'oreille monsieur
jacques pas que vous écoutez jacques lit
parfaitement chanter je suis je ne sais
rien de vous les comédiens voir les
magiciens voir les magiciens qui lui
arrive bien rester barman jacky ça ne
marchera jamais
[Musique]
charles quel est pour vous le premier
lieu associés aux vacances berck plage
ces housses à berck plage c'est ta cote
est à côté de moi merlimont plage mais
c'est tout en haut de la session
normandie
alors moi j'avais les jambes arquées 1
et à l'époque quand on avait des
déficiences dans les eaux on envoyait
les enfants à berck plage pour le
donneur pour le pour le bonheur et ça
m'a remis les gens de droite
la cat points mais les lambris vous ai
des souvenirs de bande de copains de
grosses bêtises avec les copains à berck
non à merlimont non plus n'ont pas
tellement j'ai dû toujours été un enfant
un petit peu sérieux comme on a eu un
passé assez haché difficile alors on est
con et et les enfants sérieux qu on nous
disait toujours fait attention pourquoi
se faire remarquer on a été bien reçue
dans ce pays tenez vous bien et c'est
maintenant on se connaît bien on se
tenant bien manger pour grand chose
vous avez des souvenirs d'amours de
vacances petite fille sur la plage comme
ça à berck merlimont - bram
j'ai raccroché le retard votre premier
baiser c'est à quel âge 12 ans à 12 ans
12 ans web et aider des chansons de
cette époque qui vous ont marqués en
voleurs y en a plein c'est quoi par
exemple les gars de la marine marine
elle c'est quoi les gars de la marine
joue les pères de la tournée dans les
pôles bleu marine et là bas quand j'ai
pression scientifique à d'études on
m'avait du film demandé de chanter une
chanson je chante et marielle na waie et
on m'a dit quand vous appelez jeudi à
genève orient cgt les moyens légaux
comme moyen l'argent témoin la
marseillaise
ouais on pensait que je connaissais pas
la marseillaise j'ai réussi à en sortir
quatre couples est quand même pas mal
oui parce qu'ils avaient peu de français
qui ne le savaient et l'adolescent
c'était quoi vos vacances en vacances
pourquoi parce qu'on n'avait pas les
moyens je crois que les premières
vacances ils ont des premières vacances
on les a eus à 13 ans j'ai encore une
photo de mes parents et d'un groupe de
deux d'arméniens dans l'eau jusqu'à la
ceinture et que le poing levé parce que
c'était le front populaire et que
c'étaient les premières vacances payées
vous avez déjà des chansons dans la tête
à cette époque oui j'avais déjà écrit
une chanson avec ma soeur elle a fait la
musique j'avais fait les paroles j'avais
la première chanson j'ai écrites quand
j'avais 7 8 ans c'est une histoire d'une
voiture amphibie qui parle qui allait
sur l'eau et sur la terre je me souviens
plus très bien mais ma fille ma soeur
s'en souvient alors des fois elle même
mal rappelle aujourd'hui vos vacances
c'est quoi c'est un drop et saint tropez
uniquement uniquement j'ai fait le tour
du monde plusieurs fois j'ai vu les plus
beaux coins du monde
bon je me suis arrêté à acapulco
cherboeuf requis en thaïlande
ben si peu partout que la floride la
californie le plus beaux coins du monde
c'est d'abord sur la méditerranée bon
c'est aussi la corse bien sûr mais moi
je me sens plus à l'aise ici ça me
permet de voyager d'aller en corse de
revenir et là vous avez acheté une
maison à saint tropez mais vous trouvez
pas que la région est un peu galvaudé
quand même nom que la région est très
très construit très batik donc un peu
frelaté l'était sans trembler comme
avare de boire le verre est très bien
préservés
d'autre part saint tropez c'est
l'auberge espagnole vous voulez vous
éclatez vous éclater voulait rester au
calme on rester au calme voulait leur un
coin particulier vous pouvez y aller
vous faites ce que vous voulez à saint
tropez des gens qui viennent me dire on
va passer outre aux murs il ya trop de
monde ça n'est pas vrai il ya du monde
sur le port et vient de visiter puis
reparti si vous voulez vivre normalement
on pouvait vivre en famille tout à fait
normalement mais vous qu'est ce qu'est
la première chose que vous faites quand
vous arrivez en vacances prenaient un
jour d'abord je n'arrête pas de
travailler pendant huit jours
ouais je sais pas il ya les choses
affirme dans une maison qu'on n'a pas
abandonné pendant un an
donc je fais toujours plein de choses il
faut tout revoir tout refaire et mes
vacances commencent lorsque tout est
terminé
alors au bout de huit jours qu'est ce
que vous faites après en vacances je
fais pas grand chose le matin j'ai créé
un petit peu et puis je descends sur le
sur le port pense qu'il ya pas beaucoup
de monde le matin là je prends mon
journal je me glisse trop je rencontre
les journalistes habituellement ils sont
tous là on peut faire une photo je dis
non d'ailleurs régulièrement réservé
beaucoup en vacances des journalistes il
me fiche la paix ouais on se connaît
depuis très longtemps et le côté
paparazzi ça n'existe pas surtout si on
n'a pas tellement exister en france mais
c'est vrai alors ses horaires comme ça
très très sérieux pas de déjeuner à 2h
de vous coucher tout vous coucher vers
quelle heure le soir les jeunes à 12h30
ouais je me couche vers 10h30
ah ouais avec un bouquin ménage ou
bookeen jusqu'à minuit à bout à bout
alors j'ai des choses à apprendre à
mémoriser je le fais le soir dans mon
livre c'est là qu'on apprend le mieux
vous sentez pas dans les boîtes
non j'ai eu mon temps ouais qu'est ce
que vous faites qu'on vous fait rien
alors dans la journée ah non non ça ne
m'arrive pas d'orienter d'abord j'ai
toujours quelques jeux par exemple je
sais pas moi ya toujours un prix qui a
réparé à brouillard voir quelqu'un
rencontré quelque chose à écrire un coup
de téléphone à donner
non non j'ai toujours quelque chose à
faire faites du sport en vacances n'ont
pas de sport non bonjour bull non vais
jamais au casino non non je suis pas
joueur disait pas jouer un ancien alors
pour un oriental produits tous fait des
siestes n'ont jamais n'ont même pas des
siestes crapuleuses que l'été c'est la
grande spécialité coriandre
quel est votre meilleur accessoire de
repos l'été le sable le lit où le hamac
oyonnax pas sympa il un niveau vous
devez pas vous allonger sur la plage en
matière est produite je ne me mets pas
au soleil
ouais je vis au soleil parce que
finalement ce qu'il faut c'est profiter
du soleil mais se mettre au soleil il y
en a même qui ont un truc en moins sur
le coup comme ça des fois du soleil que
dans la figure et puis à la fin de leur
vie ils ont les tâches dans tous les
sens je pense que vous faites passer
avant que l'on regardé j'ai pas
d'opération il est parfait parfait j'ai
pas mes pires si celle ci très en forme
et votre femme
elle va bien merci les clous on est sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous y mettez un peu ce bleu